we are back lakers media day
ali big game james there he is
he looks good in that uniform too
doesn't he big game
yes he does man i i like that purple
goal
russ supports you well
finally
he does look good in that uniform
doesn't he allie i mean listen being a
laker fan my whole life i never thought
i would see
russ in a laker uniform there he is ally
it looks good but look at this players
with 20 000 points 8 000 assists how
about these names big game lebron the
big o
gary payton and russ
wow oh he's here all right look at him
he looks good he's the all-time leader
in nba history with triple doubles ali's
already clapping he's a nine-time
all-star big game james has a huge smile
on his face he led the league and
assists last year i'm talking about
russell westbrook in a laker uniform how
we doing russ thanks for joining us man
oh man i'm great thank you guys for
having me i'm doing well i'm excited
about the season so look forward to it
yeah i got to say uh you're not new to
media day in a new city but this city is
la uh the team it's the lakers the team
you kind of grew up rooting for you went
to ucla this is your home i remember
when you first got traded and you spoke
to the media you kind of said it hadn't
sunk in yet maybe it was surreal how
would you describe your feelings today
going into this moment in your first
place i mean it's it's still surreal i
think i think honestly it probably won't
hit me until like open at night or
something but
i'm still just kind of triggering
everything i was soaking all in like you
know walking around media day
every once in a while i kind of look
down at my jersey like oh you know it's
a laker jersey like it's still
still all coming to me but i'm just
super excited i cannot wait you know
until we get this thing rolling and
especially rolling here with the lakers
so
you know russell welcome back home man
um it's nice to have you uh man i was
riding down
van nuys the other day and i saw the big
uh russell westbrook car dealership
just thinking
uh welcome home brother
oh yes sir thank you thank you listen
man it's so many questions man you
you're getting asked how how are you
going to flow with a.d and lebron and
all that kind of stuff and but but it's
something i've always wanted to ask you
like just watching your career
how do you define in your words uh
killer instinct
consistency
um i believe that um
to be able to have a killer instinct you
got to be able to do it consistent i
believe
i learned something a long time ago
that being consistent is the hardest
thing to do in this league
and doing the same thing every single
night over and over
takes a lot of time and energy and
effort to be to do so and i take a lot
of pride in being able to go out every
night
and leave it all on the floor and be
able to have that killer instinct
regardless of who i'm playing regardless
of the time where i'm at uh to be to do
it every night
the game that was a great question and
it kind of takes me to this point
russell welcome home great to see you
thank you
with that said i believe too that in
order for the lakers to do what they
want to do and that's obviously get back
to the top
you lebron james anthony davis starting
as the leaders have to be the best
version of yourself
and when you think of that all the while
walking that fine line of sacrifice how
do you do it
um you do what it takes for the
betterment of the team um i think when
you want to win uh nothing can get in
the way of of that the sacrifices you
have to make um and the only thing that
matters is what happens in this locker
room and on our team and that's all that
i care about and my job is to make sure
that i can uplift and make my teammates
better making
uh ron and a.d better players
as the season prolonged and along the
way making teammates around us a lot
better so that we ultimately can can
reach our goal and that's to win the
championship
russ on our shows the last few weeks
here we've talked a lot about you
joining this team joining uh lebron and
a.d and as ali mentioned the sacrifice
it takes and it got me thinking i mean
you've played with james harden you
played with kd bradley beal nobody knows
more than you how to fit with other
superstars so i ask you the simple
question what are some of the keys to
success to like have that vision that
you three have uh to making it you know
translate to winning
for me honestly i like to learn my
teammates understand them not just on
the floor but off the floor because i
think
when you learn their goals learn their
aspiration learning you know how they
operate it helps
um communication helps freak out what
guys like what they don't like and then
the basketball for me take care of
myself i'm all
into making my teammates better i want
to be able to make those guys better
make the game easy for them and i'll
figure out how to play and figure myself
out later on as the season goes along
but
honestly i really you know i just care
about winning and i've always just cared
about winning and to be able to win you
know a.d and bryan they have to be the
best they've been and uh it's my job to
make sure that i um they're to support
and do do the things i can and make them
better and oh by the way along the way
you like to have fun i i think that's
what we've learned from you following
social media
this is a two-part question i actually
hate two-part questions but i'm gonna do
it right now um you were at anthony
davis's wedding how was the wedding yes
what it was good had nice a lot of time
dancing it was great it was great
with that said
we saw you
um in photos with jared dudley someone
who is beloved here
in a laker uniform obviously won a
championship
and it's been said that you picked his
brain you just wanted to know
a little bit more what was it that you
took from that conversation why was it
important to have it
well does a good friend of mine and you
know he's obviously been around here he
knows the guys he's he knows what it
takes to win he understands um the
organization and to me i just wanted to
understand a little bit more about the
guys learn a little more about the
organization how things are ran
where does he see kind of me fitting in
what does he see you know because he's
been around he understands what it takes
been around a.d bennett brown braun and
uh i'm all in for listening i'm always
feel you can always learn more each and
every day uh from anybody and you know i
wanted to talk to him and understand a
little bit more about kind of what was
going on so he was good for that and you
know well
even though he's in dallas still can
communicate and uh you know he's still a
good friend of mine last question
i know a day doesn't go by when you
don't think about your good friend kobe
bryant he loved your game he loved your
fire how much would he have loved seeing
you in that uniform you think
man uh you know that's uh
that is a something i think about daily
you know coming to the gym you
you coming here you see you know you
look up in the practice facility you see
eight and 24
and i know you know he he is
looking down and and
you know making sure that i i need to do
what i need to do and that's the only
thing i can think about is knowing been
in this unit from understanding
the impact i can have on being home and
and being a laker um
and creating a legacy not just for
myself but for
my kids for the community of los angeles
for the people here and um you know i'm
gonna make sure i just do my part in
going out and
and playing you know for him and through
him um as i compete in this uniform
russ i know i speak for everyone at the
network we are so excited uh to have you
in the purple and gold we've always been
very proud of you representing the city
of los angeles and man it is nice to be
on the same team so thank you so much
appreciate it thank you guys i look
forward to talking to you yeah great
work on the documentary too man i
enjoyed watching it was good thank you
very much yes i appreciate it thanks
james appreciate you